so christine i gotta say um i do
interviews every day
with like a ton of people every day
right from right here in my house
and i told my wife i was like i'm
interviewing christine from um
selling sunset and she was like are you
kidding me are you joking
and she was like she told all her
friends like this is the most exciting
thing
so you know congratulations on
the success of this show needless to say
you guys are doing great
looks amazing thank you so much that
means the world to me that's that's a
really sweet compliment
and she has great taste you know it's
funny you mentioned something about
going from no social media presence like
500 000
followers um essentially overnight
right like how has how has this whole
experience like changed your life
yeah it's really interesting i mean i i
was never in the social media world i
joined when i was 30 years old so it was
a really strange thing to me
i just never had the need for it i
always lived in the moment
um so it was really weird to me you know
when i was told i had to make a social
media page
um and i did but i didn't realize
people are so mean and they go out of
their way to hate on people they don't
know and i'm like aha this is why i
didn't have social media before because
people
can be really mean so yeah it's an
interesting thing i mean i have
i think close to um almost like like 650
000 followers now and it's it's great
it's
amazing and i love to be able to connect
with my fans but it was definitely a big
culture shock for me
to say the least yeah um
congratulations on the wedding number
one i know everyone's
everybody is very excited to actually
see it
um on the show and we've got a big tease
you know with the with the preview and
everything but what can you give us in
terms of
uh what can you tell us about what it
was like what the vibe was like because
obviously it was a massive part
we know that yeah um i have to say
you know what you see on television and
what actually happened are two different
things
um my actual wedding was spectacular and
there's so many elements that weren't
shown obviously you know we had to clip
a whole entire episode um which wasn't
on my wedding into 36 minutes
which was extremely hard because we had
to bang out so many story lines in the
process of doing that
so um needless to say i was extremely
disappointed when i watched my wedding
because that's not the way i remembered
it and that's not the way that i have
footage of it happening so um i can't
wait to share my actual footage of the
wedding
to the world because it was nothing like
it was portrayed on television there
were so many cool elements that weren't
shown i had a whole entire
uh white wall when you walked in that we
you know paneled over
and we created slits with diamond gloves
and people served black champagne when
they saw people coming i mean it was
it was a real theatrical experience we
had
you know we had thunder we had lightning
we had actual snow
we had all these storms we had um
fireworks we had huge explosions we had
amazing music we had all these things
that couldn't be shown you know
i used i walked down the aisle to sweep
with psycho by ava max the violin
version it was
it was fantastic and so beautiful we
couldn't get the right set obviously
and then you know i had phantom of the
opera i mean so many great theatrical
elements
that you don't see on camera and it's
fine it is what it is
but that's the only episode i watch so
if you ask me how's the season
i'm going to say i don't know i watched
my wedding i was sad
and i peaced out so no that's not like
well i guess the silver lining there is
that you get to be the one that shows
people
you know the version of the wedding that
you want right yeah
exactly that's the way i see it i'm like
okay well you know it's up to me to
create my own narrative because
obviously i understand
they have their own vision and it's much
different from my
mind i think i think that story you just
told an interesting encapsulation of
like
the whole thing with reality television
you know
your viewers will see a situation yeah
and what they see is what they think is
actually happening have you have you had
to set the record straight for people on
social media about
your relationships or or an event that
happened in
the first two seasons of the show yeah
carlos that's actually a great question
um i learned my lesson because in season
one i was watching the show and
obviously i remember things happening a
little differently and
i would get heated because it's like oh
it wasn't that way and i want to explain
myself
but it doesn't matter what you do
unfortunately
some people really do believe everything
they see on tv
[Laughter]
yeah it's hard it's hard not to get
heated and want to like explain things
to people and be like no
this is why i did this this is why i did
this but none of them
it's okay but part of the appeal of
uh the show not just like the beautiful
homes that you guys show off
is i think people want to see the sort
of um
ups and downs of the relationships
between you and your co-workers and
they'll lead into things
like it's their life or like it's their
friends yeah um
you know the relationship that you have
with krishel
looks like it's strange when you watch
the show
you know and very recently she had
said on social media that you had
mentioned something about her
um her marriage yeah
that wasn't true like can you set the
record straight about what that whole
interaction was yeah i mean if you guys
actually watched the interview that i
did
i don't know if you did but the
interviewer simply asked me
um you know do you know justin hartley
what's he like or something like that i
was like yeah i know justin i've met him
plenty of times
he's great he's spectacular and you know
i know they were having problems
and i guess she just got mad that i
spoke out on her behalf and also i was
painting a positive picture of justin
because i do know him as well and he's
been nothing but kind to me
so i'm just going on the information
that i'm given and
i have one person who's been fabulous to
me and one person who
repeatedly doesn't want to be in the
same room with me and film with me so
i'm just trying to navigate like the
limited information that i'm
given and i answered the question
honestly yeah
i think it's really interesting that you
know you've mentioned a couple of times
now just
the sort of the learning curve about
this like it's the social media one and
then also the one about being
on tv and then in social media for you
know
the viewer's impression of you is
someone who kind of like um takes no bs
from people
and you're okay with confronting people
with whatever issues um but have you had
to kind of
either reign things back or kind of
learn over the
course of filming that oh you know what
i can't actually
kind of say this right now because
something's going to be taken out of
context
um that's a great question i um
i think that all of us girls have
learned to
reel it in a little bit because we
watched
how things come together in the editing
room and after season one we were
extremely frightened
um so season two we went into it and we
were a little more careful
um however there's been times where i've
done interviews
and i'm an honest person and sometimes
production doesn't like that
so in terms of me having to reel myself
back it comes from a different
standpoint
it doesn't come from me and the show it
comes from me wanting to discuss
the elements that go into filming the
television show which i can't obviously
speak on
um so i would say that's the only slap
on the wrist i've had other than that
i'm gonna
continue to keep being me and being
honest and i think that's what people
like about me and i think that's why
people love the show
yeah absolutely how has married life
been so far
mary life's been great i mean
we've been stuck in the house so
obviously it kind of stops
but we're having a great time together i
just wish we could
you know go on vacation somewhere but
that's fine
it's like a weird honeymoon we're just
stuck in the house together i'm like
okay fine have any of your um
co-workers or co-stars come see you for
any marriage advice
um no not yet but i uh i talked to
heather the other day and i was like i'm
so excited for you
i'm so happy for you i mean she's
engaged she's wanted to just be like
married her whole life she's a helpless
romantic
so um i told her i was like if you need
help planning the wedding let me know
like i'm so excited because i'm a
planner and um
she's like i'm not that far are you
crazy i'm like okay well let me know i
helped you
so um not quite yet i'm trying though
yeah um you know we were talking just
now about the appeal of the show
obviously the relationships i watch and
i go these houses
are incredible i think about like the
work that goes into
you know staging um selling the house
trying to get people to be interested in
it what's something that people aren't
seeing in the show
even though they're getting sort of
insight into that line of work
that they should know about being a
realtor and actually
you know working with these massive
homes and these and these clients that
just
seem to have an unlimited amount of
money i think there's a lot of
interesting factors that go into
buying a home and selling at home and
you're going to see in season three
that um i go head-to-head with one of my
clients davina brings me on to sell a
home
and it's a fabulous home it's on a great
plot of land it's huge it's a proper
compound however
i'm having a hard time wrapping my head
around the numbers you know there's a
lot of factors that go into play which
include
you know streets roads um school
districts
so many so many things um noise view i
mean just tons of things that you're not
seeing also comps in the area is it the
biggest home in the area because it's
never going to sell i mean there's a lot
of factors that go into these homes
um externally that you're not seeing on
the show
which is why some homes don't sell that
are fabulous and
why some that aren't so fabulous sell
you know it's a really interesting thing
it's
really all about location location is
everything
so given that you've only seen that
wedding episode
of season three how are you preparing
yourself to watch
the rest of the season you must be
interested in seeing how the whole thing
pans out
i'm not i'll be honest with you i'm not
so i actually did an
interview with cosmo uk last night
um well actually this morning
technically um so they sent over a few
clips and it was like reaction scenes
from the most dramatic
moments so i saw like you know 15 second
clips like 10 of those
i get the gist i get the gist
um i don't know maybe i'll go back and
watch it but
i mean like am i in the mood to be
disappointed and like surprised and
shocked like probably not
i want to keep the memories in my head
that were actually real let's just say
that
so how much longer do you think that
you'd be um
interested in doing this for television
then
i mean you think you would do a four
five six i mean yeah of course i just i
learned the hard way you know i feel
like you learn
things every season and i had a wedding
and i spent a lot of money for it i was
really really excited
and unfortunately it wasn't really
it wasn't really like received well it
wasn't really showcased
well so i just know for next season like
i'm not
i'm not going to have events like that
because i just feel like it's always an
instagram opportunity for these girls
and that's it
i'm like can we show my event please
right well i mean you if you're going to
do another scene you can't deprive the
fans of a big event
like a big christine event so you know
i'm going to implore that you maybe
think about that one again okay maybe
just for you and your wife
okay yeah oh perfect yeah she'll be very
happy to hear that